You're okay. Hello. It's September 16.
We're in Cohort, one of the
active textbook group. It's meeting 15,
or I guess yes, no, 16 on
let me just update the title meeting
16. We're in our second discussion on
chapter six. So are there any any
overall comments that people would like
to address about chapter six or
any other questions or points to add or
just areas of chapter six that they
found to be interesting.
Distinction between the interceptive
extraceptive modalities
which have been mentioned in box 6.1.
And I think
Kristen with Michael Allen,
if I'm not mistaken, has published a
recent paper just today,
exactly on that topic, in which they've
somehow tried to provide a
computational model for the first time
for the unification of the interceptive
and extraceptive modalities. So since
this chapter is also the
modeling of those agents, I think this
paper, from in the Body's Eye
the computational anatomy of
interceptive inference might be relevant
for anyone who wants to model these
modalities with the aid of active
inference framework. Thank you.
Very nice. Thanks for sharing it.
Let's look at box 61.
As people see it, what distinguishes
exteriorceptive proprioceptive and
interoceptive modalities?
For example, why are proprioceptive and
interceptive separated?
Because I couldn't hear you. I don't
know if it's on my side or connection
was unstable from your side. Sorry. Let
me try something. I'll be on for a
second.
Am I back? Okay. So,
yeah. What? Yeah, brock, I do need a
starlink. Why are proprioception
and terraception separated?
And why are these three categories
modeled as different? Why have they been
framed as different.
Biological and neurological mechanisms,
neural mechanisms that somehow
control those different kind of
perceptions? Because for the
extraceptive perception,
the organism would
necessarily need a kind of sensory
I mean, the sensation it gets
from the environment is just on
the level of the
imminent stimuli that it gets from the
external environment. But for the
interceptive modality,
the sensation is just the internal
sensations and so on. And for the
preceptive, it's related to motor
control feedback loop. So I
guess because of their different
mechanisms it might be
helpful to talk in different terms
about each of them. But I'm not totally
sure about that.
I agree. I think one aspect, even in a
pre blanket or non blanket modality is
like they're about external things
versus about internal things. And then
between proprioception and
interoception, you're absolutely right
that they have different neural
mechanisms and physiological mechanisms
with some blurry space,
perhaps. For example, like interoception
about blood pressure is somewhere in
between, like a muscular reflex and an
organ reflex, but the tissues being
addressed are different. Let's look at
this paper again. We'll return to the
book, but we're going to be thinking
today and then especially going forward
with like, how do you identify
the let's go
to this question, which we just look at
it. Which system are we modeling?
What is the appropriate form for the
generative model. How do we set up a
generative model? How do we set up a
generative process? So let's see if we
can determine some of those aspects.
In this paper,
hashtag figure 43, it is the very
same.
Okay, this is just a general pointing to
a partially observable Markov decision
process with a slight plus
computational biology graphical veneer
to match the color scheme. Probably not,
but it kind of looks like it.
Here is where we see the schematic
of the form of the generative model.
Variables are used to reflect
that those variables can be fit from
empirical data or just a priori set and
simulated. But this is the form of the
model. These are the shapes of the
matrices and tensors that go
from that are going to address
what their model is about.
Does anybody want to describe what they
see in this?
What do you think they were trying to
explain and what do
you think they were trying to model?
What is their system of interest based
upon what you see here?
Actually, one interesting term that I
came up with used in this
paper is cardiac
active inference. The term that they've
used in this paper to describe the
kind of interrelationship between the
heart rhythm and the
interception. So this generative
model, I believe, is just
about modeling that relationship between
the heart rhythm and the interception.
So we can see, as usual,
the B matrices C and A matrices that
we've seen before, but in this case,
they've been applied to the variation
in the heart rhythm and how it relates
to the interception. Yes.
So again, using the variables that
we know from figure four three in the
book and their figure one here, the
hidden states that are not directly
observed are on the
interceptive side relating to the state
of the heart. On the exteriorceptive
side, whether there is a flower or a
spider.
The outcomes that are observed are the
visual exterocception of a flower or a
spider and the heart rate probably
a low and a high heart rate.
The piece that links these two is the
sensory attenuation between
the high heart rate state and the
mapping of exterocception in
the B matrix. You can just see that even
the allocation of the symbols is
different. Like when you're aroused,
when you're in, this is like heart open
and then heart contract. So when
you're in the aroused situation, b is
how the hidden states change their time.
You're always going to go from here to
here,
whereas in the relaxed situation,
sometimes you go from
this state to this one.
Other times you're relaxed and so you
dwell within that state. So here it's
like pump rest, pump rest, pump rest.
Here it's 50% slower. Just it depends
on the parameters, but it's 50% slower
because sometimes you're going to go
from one, but it looks like as it's here
that it's actually like or it's twice as
slow. Rest, rest, beat.
Rest, rest, beat. So these are the two
interoceptive states.
One has a preference for having
relaxed hearts when flowers are around
and having contracted heart when spiders
are around. The A matrix
maps on these two sensory modalities
between hidden states and outcome
states, just like any A matrix would
do in any POMDP. And then
there's also a transition matrix of the
generative process. So it's a very
simple generative process where either
flowers are flowers or spiders are
spiders,
as they would say. You can use standard
routines to simulate these techniques.
I hope that the code are available.
You can plot parameter sweeps
as you explore the beta and alpha.
So here's, like the beta parameter and
alpha parameter. So you can do parameter
sweeps with this grid search or other
approaches and then do statistics on
those outputs. Is this quote active
inference? Well, it's the output of a
parameter sweep on an active inference
model. There's various other kinds of
methods. So, not to spend too much time
on the paper, but does
anyone have any thoughts on that case
or how they see it applying to chapter
six as content?
I think it speaks to a fulfillment cycle
in active inference research.
Oh.
This worked example helps a lot.
I mean, if anyone wants to,
especially because describing
this kind of cardiac active inference as
a kind of system that has
a definite Markov blanket, it was
really interesting question at the first
place. And I think they've done really
great job, obviously, in that regard and
thinking really creatively and out of
the box about how we
can describe that whole system with
the aid of using markup blankets to
describe its internal and external
environment and so on.
It also relates to this earlier
question. So how does the figure 43
paradigm discrete and
continuous state spaces with all the
attending complexities? Do you hear me,
Ollie? Okay,
how does this representation connect
to. Can you hear,
Daniel? Yeah, I can.
It's a story for another day. Some of
the incredible, the truly incredible
Internet. I'm going to try one thing.
So I think that or Holly, can. You hear
me now? Or no.
I'll try something.
It here's what's interesting with the Wi
Fi. And then we'll continue, because
it's not a Wi Fi learning group, but
with the Hotspot, there are a set of
people who I cannot interact with,
but with WiFi, I am able to interact
with those people. Just a
note. So we
see the POMDP representation.
Now, what is not in this paper
here is a graphical layout of
the POMDP.
Okay? What is not in this paper? A
figure six one, or indeed a figure
eleven representation.
So why is that's?
I'm not sure I've understood your
question quite clearly, but could
you please elaborate on that a little
bit more? Yes, sure. So when we look at
papers like Vassal at all,
communication is active inference
social, inactive, active inference,
loops, loops, loops, viotkin at all
remote teams. Loops, loops, loops,
Markov blanket interface loops,
entities, things.
Yet in the application,
what is specified is not the loopy
situation. What needs to be specified is
chapter six, not chapter one.
So I find that very interesting because
so much of the focus attention,
discourse has been around abstractions,
around Markov blankets and their
interpretations from various stances and
about boundaries, physical boundaries
and conceptual boundaries.
But it's a non controversy when
it's written this way. And there
are Markov blankets between many of
these variables because it's a Bayesian
graph that's not fully connected. So
every Bayesian graph that's not fully
connected has Markov blankets.
Trivially. But this
paper doesn't need to
describe what
is. This is enough to say what's inside
and outside the organismal. Markov
blanket, if we want to even think about
it, is like here in this line, kind of
not on the Bayes graph, but it's between
the spider and the flower outside and
the vision of the spider and the flower.
But that's like taken care of
with the a matrix of the exterocceptive
modality, which is,
I think, why this recipe does
not focus on which
thing are we modeling, but rather which
system are we modeling. And yes, we're
going to pursue the generative model
before the generative process, even
though they may have symmetry or they
may be very similar.
But I just find it very interesting,
open to hearing what people think, like
why the Cybernetic
loop action perception loop is
used so much in
contrast with the form of the model
that's actually implemented,
which is a different topology in a
different discussion.
I know that they're integrated and
compatible.
Just one comment on that is, you see,
at least to my understanding, markup
blanket is a
kind of modeling tool or a
way of thinking about basically
the ontology of I mean ontology
in the sense of its philosophical use,
the ontology of the system that we're
about to model. So it's
not necessarily the
relationships among the different
components of the markup blanket is
something not necessarily physical
or tangible relationships in that
system. So it might be kind
of just informational,
as we
saw in, I think, chapter five, if I'm
not mistaken, the information passing
among the different components and so
on. So at least
I think the reason for not using the
Schematic model of markup I mean the
Cybernetic model of Markup blanket
instead of using just the Schematic
form, probably it's because of this
kind of, let's say
nonphysical or nontangible relationship
among the different components. By
nontangible and nonphysical I mean
something that can't be explained
in terms of its ontological
existence. I don't
know if I could express myself in
that regard or not.
Thank you, Elite, Brock and anyone else.
I was just going to I
don't know, I feel like personally,
I'm just kind of at the
affordances that I have to get
pragmatic and epistemic value here
without doing some modeling of some
kind.
Yeah, I don't know. Good.
Thanks. I mean, this is the second
discussion on chapter six, and then this
is setting us up to actually pursue a
model. So we should be preparing these.
Yeah. I'm just saying it's definitely
ripe for that.
Yes. Rohan.
Yeah, actually, just to get some
clarification, you're asking why the
form of the model is as mentioned in
chapter six of the project given in
chapter six, which is chapter one.
Yes. I mean, they're compatible.
Topologies that actually are describing
an overlapping set of notes.
I was just calling attention to the
amount of discourse and focus on the
potentially more familiar, more
schematic action perception loop and
the way that that draws so much
attention to the organism environment
interface. Whereas when it comes
to the empirical modeling,
that interface never had to be specified
as like a first class type.
It just was included by the buy. We just
said there are spiders and flowers out
there, hidden states, s, and then
there's observations of and there's no
error. There's no
error. Right. But there would be no
error in the generative process itself.
The model might have error that
comes from some measurement issue.
Right? So when you measure it and you
confuse, say, spider for flower or
flower for spider, then you would get
some error. And there may be that's
where I guess you can talk about the
markup blanket misspecifying
or misobserving something.
So I'm not sure what
exactly is. The. I mean,
they're compatible, right? In this case,
there's no error. But if there was
error, obviously there would be
something wrong with the.
Let me actually just correct this. I
believe be I didn't mean to say
this is the visual error. This is saying
that they're unchanging flowers, so
they're either one or the other. Here.
Parametrically it's possible to
introduce visual error in the A matrix.
But I'm just pointing to the
architecture of the model doesn't
require even engaging with this.
It's totally compatible. And the
observations are the sense states and
the actions are the active states and so
on, but as presented
and as constructed,
if we're going to use a POMDP
architecture, we don't necessarily even
need a representation like this.
Yeah. Jessica okay,
that's interesting.
Hi. Yes. For me,
the reason why it's
like two parts, the reason why the craft
is so popular, and I think maybe it's
also the reason why it was used.
And this is the simplicity to show the
concept and the relationship like the
new one. It's great for, I guess, for
the paper that it was created, but it
doesn't show the relationship as clear
as the other ones. It's very simple. So
I think that's why it was used. Maybe
like, remove a lot of extra information
that the second paper illustrates in
it. But the simplicity of that graph is
why it really encapsulates the concept.
And it's also the reason why it's so
popular, because it's so simple. I think
that's the relationship, I think,
from how I see it.
Yes, totally makes sense. Thank you.
And once we see that there is a mapping
from the Schematic cybernetic view,
then we can probably fill in a lot of
the parts of the PMDP. But just to look
one more level here, I posted the code
below, so it's in MATLAB
which people may or may not have access
to. Sorry. Okay. Ali and then Ron.
No, I just wanted to point out one thing
that I forgot to mention before.
One thing that might be helpful to keep
in mind is that actually, in this
generative model, there is a kind of
unification, or kind of integration of
interceptive and extraceptive
modalities. Because, as they pointed out
in the paper,
this agent that they're modeling adopts
two modes of engagement with the world,
one of which is the relaxed and the
other one is the aroused
mode of engagement. And because of that,
there are two sorts of hidden states
related to each interceptive and
extraceptive one. So I guess if
they wanted to put that kind of
interrelationships between these kind of
modalities in that simplified
schematic model, it wouldn't necessarily
clarify these kind of integration
between the modalities. So one reason
might be related to that peculiar
situation of this particular case here.
Thanks. It also speaks to the step in
the model of the form of a generative
model. And then I think when people get
married to the cybernetic scheme,
you can imagine, well, then there's two
nodes inside of the internal states.
There's two modes you can go between.
But now you're like, mixing and matching
what arrows mean, where some of the
arrows are reflecting causal influence
and some of them are reflecting
transitions between mutually exclusive
states. And so then we end up back into
the wireframe nightmare, where it's like
a schematic, where some edges are
tactile connections and some are causal
links and some are mutually exclusive
transfers of information and all these
other ways that people visualize models.
And this representation reminds us that
we're dealing with variables and states
and their connections. Jessica.
I think that was from before. Okay.
I think the visual has
to do with what are you trying to convey
in that moment and how much depth
of information do you need? I think,
like, at least for this one, you need an
extra information so that all the model
wouldn't work. Well,
just share with the idea of what the
model is. Maybe this version with
the extra information might be too
complex for the other one. There's a
better purpose. What is the purpose
you're trying to accomplish,
and what do you want to communicate?
And depending on that, then models with
more information or less information are
more successful. Yes.
Thank you. Totally agree. I mean, they
didn't do any of the loop at all. They
just went straight to the PMDP
representation. And also, this isn't the
only form of an interoceptive
exterocceptive integration model. One
could brainstorm a whole host. And
again, that's what the recipe is for.
Well, we could have a mutually exclusive
transfer between these two states
defined by these two B matrices,
which entails a policy variable
switching between the two. Or we could
have a continuous variable called
arousal. And arousal is engaged in some
sort of attenuation relationship here.
So this isn't even the only form, but it
shows us a form.
Okay,
soon, in 20 minutes, we're going to be
heading into chapter seven. So let's
preview it so that when we're
working on this in the next week,
preparing our questions, starting to
think about what we want to be modeling,
we'll kind of know what's going to
happen. All right, chapter seven is
active inference in discrete time.
People can still hear me okay. I think
so. All right, so here
is where we cross the rubicon
with modeling.
This is abstract up till now.
You cut out there for a second. Okay.
It's all good now. Yeah.
Just start from the review. Thank you.
Chapter seven, we're crossing the
rubicon together,
and it's been abstract up till now.
First, what is addressed is perceptual
processing. You'll find a lot of
resonance between this chapter
seven and Step
by Step,
which is model stream one. Maybe it's
Stephen.
This paper step by step tutorial is
going to do a certain walkthrough of
adding incremental complexity into the
model in terms of model parameter depth.
Okay. It's model stream one. There's
four streams that Ryan and Chris White
did. Static perception,
dynamic perception, dynamic perception
with preferences and free energy
minimization. Dynamic perception with
free energy minimization and flexible
policy selection through uncertainty
modulation. We're going to do something
similar in chapter seven.
They don't do that upper left
corner of step by step. They go straight
to hidden Markov models for dynamic
perception. This is analogous to a
Coleman filter or any other number of
General Bayesian filtering schemes. We
have a prior D hidden states S and
a sequence of observables through time T
that are mapped to hidden states. A B
describes how hidden states change
through time. So we have the temperature
is a hidden variable. And then we're
getting observations from the
thermometer that are mapped to the real
temperature by A. Maybe it's a good
thermometer, maybe it's biased or
whatever. And then there's the
temperature changing through time.
Then there's a very Ollie Centric
discussion of listening to music. This
has to be one of the most glaring errors
in the textbook.
It's very warhol like, though, so maybe
it has a certain aesthetic to it.
But the example that's going to be
provided is like a musical listening
example. So the
A matrix is emitting notes
based upon the hidden state, which is
the score of the music. The B matrix
is and they have 70% accuracy. So this
one 10th distributes through the matrix.
So it's just to use, like, integers
here. But really this is like zero 7.1.1
.1, because it has to add up to one.
But when this person, when the hidden
state of the score is in the first note,
they play it 70% of the time. And then
the other three notes, they make an
error 10% of the time. Each time, 70% of
the time, the musician hits their note.
The B matrix is how things change
through time, the hidden state. So this
is the transitions in the score. And
here there's a 97% probability. Again,
it's distributed throughout with this
one over 100 just to represent it with
integers. And there's a prior with no
uncertainty or ambiguity of just it
begins in the first position. And so
this we can even see, like do do you
know, I don't want to use ABCD, but it
would be like BCDA in the musical
ontology. So here's BCCDA like
that. But then there is an error
in this one simulation run. It'd be
probabilistic, but they're showing for
didactic reasons, a run where the third
point in the third observation, there is
an error. However, it's heard as
the correct value.
That's a pure inference example. This is
not active inference. This is just
Bayesian models of perception.
This kind of sessile creature is rather
uninteresting. Okay,
now we move from a hidden Markov model
crotching tiger, hidden Markov, into a
partially observable Markov decision
process. A hidden Markov model is a
partially observable Markov model
because some parts of it are hidden,
some are not. But the key piece here is
the introduction of the decision. We
know that we model that with policy that
influences how states change their time,
and that policy selection is governed by
g. Figure four three people
can still hear because I see all these,
like, frozen for me.
Okay, all right. Okay, thank you. Yeah,
it's just strange stuff here's four
three again,
here when we're talking about policy
selection, we're talking about states
that haven't happened yet,
observations, and hidden states that
haven't happened yet. We see a
restatement of equation 2.6 with
expected free energy here, broken into
epistemic and pragmatic value.
Now, to flesh out this POMDP,
we turn to a classic par and Friston
example, which is the teammase.
We're not going to go through every
single part of this teammase right now,
but it'll be a key area for us to
unpack. Why do the matrices have
the dimensions that they have?
Where are the four locations that the
mouse can be here,
down at the bottom, to the left or to
the right? So this is not like a mouse
moving in continuous space. It's like
there are four locations it can be in.
Those are the columns. There's five
hidden states of location which
we can see are like, based upon whether
when it goes down to the bottom to get
a queue, whether the hidden
state is going to reveal the queue or
not. And then figure seven,
four and 75 you'll see differ.
First off, one of them is bolded, this
one is bolded, this one's unbolded. But
here we see a one in the L column
because the black is on the L. And here
we see a one in the R column because the
black is on the R. So understanding why
that is is going to be the crux of
understanding how to construct an
epistemic informative q as
a hidden environmental variable in a
generative model. Here are the B
matrices transition probabilities.
Here's the preference vector. We'll talk
about what C one and C two are. Here are
the priors we'll talk about what D one
and D two are. Now there's more
unpacking of the epistemic value
itself. So in the equation
above there was a restatement of
equation 2.6 which partitions the
expected free energy into the negative
epistemic value and the pragmatic value.
Now we're going to follow up on the
epistemic value I
of pi the epistemic value of a policy
and break that down into these
representations.
Here are simulations,
simulated epistemic and pragmatic
behavior of a rat foraging in a
teammates. So we'll try
to model what these runs are. I think it
might be one small note about the book
that especially if they knew that it was
going to be black and white, which it
seems like that was known,
this is not ultra helpful.
Perhaps people disagree. But another
war. What said
another warhol? Yeah,
this one you can even see the Campbell
soup. But I think
if someone were familiar with reading
these traces, they would still want
to understand what these different lines
were and like what the dashed one is.
But if people are unfamiliar reading
these kinds of error residual traces,
I don't know what is being shown here
figure 7.7. That was the simulation
of the rat getting the epistemic queue
and going to the left. So instead of
just taking a 50 50 shot on where the
food was, the rat navigates this
explore exploit dilemma. It engages in
an epistemically oriented action or an
action driven by epistemic value to
reduce uncertainty, get the queue and
then it secures the food.
In this box 71 we see
a discussion about parameterization of
uncertainty and how precision is
the inverse of variance. And this omega
is the precision variable here,
just like Mark Solms uses, but others
use different ones.
The lower this value is,
the more even things are.
And so this has come up in the ice cream
example with the folk psychology live
stream. Like if your c vector
is zero
six negative six versus
zero 500 negative 500, that's like
a sharper preference distribution.
So it's the quantitative values in the
C, for example, that specified not
just the direction but also the
intensity of preference. And then
analogously precision can be specified
in a continuous form. Here is
a reference to an earlier par and
Friston work on vision that has to
do with ocular motor foraging, which is
heavily epistemically driven. But then
they are using this example to
explore how precision the
viewer shows a version to the upper left
square when it is specified with a less
precise, more ambiguous likelihood.
Mapping the lower left square
is epistemically attractive when the
transition probabilities are specified
as more uncertain.
We'll try to understand these examples.
Learning a Novelty 7.5 here
we take that POMDP and we push
it back in the genealogy. Now we
have priors on the hidden states which
are themselves equipped with prior
beliefs. These are dear Schlee conjugate
priors, but they can be of other forms.
But they're just shown as dear Schlee
here because it's like a convenient
statistical distribution family for
variational inference which we explored
in several chapters ago.
These can be considered as hyper priors,
but in the end just variables on the
graph. And it's not like they're tagged
with being a hyper prior and you can
imagine priors that nest on them.
Exploring these potentially open ended
Bayesian graph structures is why it's so
important to have structure learning,
like Karl has pointed out for years,
and why we want to have parameter sweeps
across cognitive model structures in
active block prints. Because why stop?
Why not have another prior on this one?
So we should have the notation and the
capacity to sweep that.
Here is a discussion on conjugate
priors. A conjugate prior means
that when used to perform Bayesian
inference, the posterior belief will be
the same type of distribution. So
previously we talked about how like the
hidden state could be a continuous
variable and then the internal state
could be like a discrete variable. The
temperature is continuous outside and
then inside is it hot or is it cold? Is
like what I'm caring about. So the
families don't have to match. But when
we use conjugate priors it
makes it so that where you
can design it to play nice. It does play
nice, but we'll work through that also
with anybody who wants to go into more
detail on the math because these are
just like Bayesian statistics points.
Here theta is used to just describe
parameters. It's a very common notation,
but not 100% pervasive to use theta for
parameters, just generally here
there's more unpacking of the update
rules. This is probably of secondary
consideration for just constructing a
model.
Here we return to expected free energy
and several more representations beyond
what was seen above and beyond what was
seen in equation 2.6.
Here the learning model that was
presented above the POMDP with another
generation of genealogy is described
which is drawn from these two papers.
Then structured learning is introduced.
We'll see how deep this one goes. But
these papers are quite interesting and
connected to Bayesian model reduction.
Here a hierarchical model is presented
here's figure 43 in the dashed box.
Now there's a figure 43 yo dog. I heard
you liked figure four, three.
Then there's another hierarchical
model simulation from the above showing
belief updating again with these trace
diagrams.
And then there's a summary.
So it's a somewhat long chapter.
It contains like, the music example,
the rat example,
the maze example, the eye example.
So we're seeing like, data points in
model space, um,
in the last three minutes. Does anyone
have any thoughts or questions? How are
they going to tackle chapter seven?
And as they start to construct their
model, if they want to?
I am just every
direction that I can because it is
quite dense still and kind of
unapproachable, I think, for me anyways,
it just is quite difficult to get a
grasp on it from the textbook
specifically at this point,
like the generative model, like, what
does that mean in code? And where does
that correlate to this particular
function or that particular time step or
whatever? I don't know.
It's just a lot. And so I'm just trying
to.
From. Yeah, I don't know, from just
generally building up simulations,
which are just things that you can put
together in a browser, like with simple
JavaScript to Cadcad and active
block prints and these sorts of things
and trying to grasp
at some real world situation. So maybe
that rat Tmaze is a really good
place to focus on for me, like a good
intersection between the book and
something that isn't like the frog
jumping or is it not jumping is so
contrived. It's really difficult to
think about modeling that and in a way
that would help explain what's going
it's like, yes, I knew the frog was
jumping or not jumping, so that doesn't
really help. Right. Whereas the rat
maybe coming up with some left or right
hidden state based on the queue that's
partially there's some explanatory power
there that may be realized, I think.
I don't know. I'm trying to
bridge jump over the Grand Canyon of the
philosophical conceptual okay, got it.
But the math there's. Okay. But there's
a gap there for me, so I'm trying to
pull them together.
Yeah. I have a question related to
calibration of those priors and among
other things, is that ever explained
as to how to go about doing that for
any of these models? Yes.
So model based data
analysis is going to describe all
right, chapter seven describes just in
our last minute. Chapter seven describes
the discrete state models. Chapter eight
describes continuous time models.
Chapter nine describes using empirical
data for model driven data analysis.
Chapter ten is a summary. The textbook
is. Yeah, we're excited
towards. The Grand Canyon, but I think,
again, we have several months to unpack
this together. So I hope that we can go
quite far with this. So please stay
engaged and add your questions and start
building from both sides. Play with the
code examples provided, break them and
then start from the other side with a
recipe on a situation that you care
about, and then they're going to meet in
the middle. Okay,
thank you, everyone. Farewell.
Bye, everyone.